[Music]
25 into Wednesday morning what's driving
you crazy how about riding shotgun on
the latest changes to the HOV lanes in
Nevada
on Monday the Nevada Transportation
board voted to change the hours of HOV
lane operations back to what they were
years ago rush hours only except now
they'll be even shorter mornings from 6
to 8 A.M afternoons from 4 to 6 p.m and
while electronic signs are relatively
easy to change the Department of
Transportation is Justin Hopkins points
out that there are a lot of physical
signs to switch over to
the transportation board wants the new
hours to go into effect within 30 days
and as for the possibility of getting
rid of HOV lanes don't expect that to
happen anytime soon if ever Hopkins
points out that with interstate and U.S
highways being part of the federal
government that requires Outreach to
constituents stakeholders lots of
Environmental Studies those typically
take 18 to 24 months or even longer so
until sometime next month the current
HOV rules are still in effect so two or
more people per vehicle between 5 a.m
and 10 p.m buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone you can join
the driving you crazy conversation at
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com